[Applause]
congratulations
[Music]
from the Punjab to our Parliament this
is a journey over Generations that
reminds us we should be celebrating and
always celebrate the migrants who
contribute so much to our country over
will give us alleged failure to meet the
terms of his contract and we're waiting
for them for me
[Music]
thank you
um
my solemn promise and commitment to you
is that I will Kickstart our Grassroots
or Civic led to movement and ensure our
drive for Independence is in fifth gear
the people of Scotland need Independence
now more than ever before and we will be
the generation that delivers
Independence for Scotland
foreign